[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cook do you hear me Roger
[Applause]
after eating your miraculous space chili
no idea what you mean
our food is healthy captain to crew dead
monkey in the crow's nest I repeat
monkey down Spanky strikes again ha P
that captain a page where we could use
your space jelly till four o'clock our
engines
negativo me amor only you can melt my
circuits keep laughing fools Q brilliant
- good cookin is
[Music]
Engineering to officers we are dead in
the water
I repeat dogs come in
what have we gonna live gathered Chuck
[ __ ]
nada I hate white I see something
three o'clock starboard it is massive
but get back here Sonny
hold off
lock down the Baker
Wow
[Music]
gods protect us
Jade
[Applause]
thank you
fine
hello I'm Gabrielle Schrager narrative
director and I'm Giovanni senior
producer we are so happy to be back this
year to share our progress on our space
opera beyond knievel - a game full of
wonder emotion danger and high-stakes
drama last year you all saw the
enigmatic green eyed captain bikini
leading the legendary crew of the god on
a quest to discover the location and the
mystery behind a deep-space artifact
known as moksha
but the kini has since gone missing
Shanny is now captain of the gather and
she's leading a crew into the deep
unexplored space beyond system 3 when
they come face to face with their
nemesis fans will have recognized a
ferocious young Jade and Paige is back
as the incorrigibles Eve cook of the
gada we've got two other officers uma
the holistic chief medic and Callum our
chief engineer and all of these
legendary characters will be playing a
major role in our prequel today we are
proud to represent our growing
production team in Montpellier Barcelona
Bordeaux and Sofia thanks everyone for
making it happen
[Applause]
and thank you for them it be in BG to
your space pirate captain in a distant
galaxy near the end of the 24th century
at this year's e3 we will be showcasing
a new behind-closed-doors demo offering
a first look at our major location the
sacred city of Ganesha now let's take a
look at our first free alpha gameplay
footage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ganesha is a metropolis filled with
sacred temples beautiful gardens and
bustling shops but it's also a darker
underworld rife with dirty bars and
dangerous back alleys our game is an
action-adventure RPG that you can play
alone or with your friends in coop from
the intimate interior of a hidden temple
to the very edge of the galaxy fight on
the ground and in space at massively
different scales and all of this
seriously what you'll be seeing at e3
this year is only a very small part of a
much larger open universe we are
creating a universe we are also building
with our fans yeah let's go with B on
gravel - we want our community to
participate in a way that's never been
done before through the space monkey
program we want our fans and people all
over the world to really be a part of
creating the game so today we are
issuing an open invitation for people
all over the world to contribute their
ideas music art works and create
original content that players will
experience as they explore the world of
beyond greevil - and there is literally
a universe of ways for artists to
express themselves from giant frescoes
to murals street art music radio content
and much more to do this we have
partnered with a company at the
forefront of community collaboration hit
record and here to tell us more is their
founder Joseph gordon-levitt
[Applause]
sister thank you
I love this theater so thanks thanks to
you guys thanks Guillaume and and thanks
Gabriel it's really good to be here I'm
super excited to do this for those of
you don't know hit record is this thing
I've been making for a long long time
it's really dear to me and it's a place
where people all over the world work
together on short films or music or art
all kinds of projects this is the first
time we're making stuff that's going to
go into a video game so it's a little
bit different than other like creative
platforms that you can find on the
internet because the point of hit record
it isn't just to post and promote stuff
that you've made on your own the point
is to collaborate so like when we're
making music for Beyond Good and Evil 2
it's not just gonna be a thing like a
contest where people submit songs and
then we pick one or two of them when we
put them in the game we're gonna be
really making the songs together and the
same goes for the visual assets that
we'll be creating
so whether you're a writer a musician
and illustrator if you're a pro level
artist or if you're just someone who
really cares about Beyond Good and Evil
in that world and you love it and you
want to be a part of it there's gonna be
ways for you to contribute our first
creative challenges are live as of like
now someone's at my office pushing the
button like very nervous but you guys
you're doing great and yeah so come to
our site check out the Beyond Good and
Evil 2 page at hitRECord org and that's
it go do that [ __ ] thanks
[Applause]
[Applause]
hit records approach to community
collaboration is inspiring and were
incredibly happy to be working with
Joseph Emma's team and we really can't
wait to see what the community creates
so let's do it we will be showcasing
some of this content out our very first
dedicated community event the BG Fest
which will take place in Montpelier this
fall
thanks everyone have a great three
[Applause]
[Music]